[Applause]
please
[Applause]
oh my god
oh i'm overwhelmed you almost have me
crying back there well actually um that
leads me to a question about when you
were auditioning for
steven spielberg
um
there was a moment where you did break
down is that correct yeah well we were
doing um
a boy like that i have a love and i was
really really in it and i was you know
cutting and bleeding and giving
everything i had to give to the moment
and by the end of it i was in the floor
and i'm crying
completely losing my mind and i look up
and there's stephen and he had a like a
halo around him
and
he he reached out and i was like this
feels like god reaching out to adam on
the sistine chapel and he
picked me up in his arms and he just
said thank you
and and then i realized he's crying with
me and then i looked around and the
whole room is crying and we're all
crying and i was just like this might be
one of the most
beautiful moments i've ever had as an
actor to because my whole goal is to
make people feel well
mission accomplished in this movie wild
i mean
this film is so much more than a film i
think it's what we really all need right
now um it's magnanimous
but it's such a thrill too i mean please
tell me the story of when you are
dancing
in those famous dancer shoes
but oh my god the ones i burned holes in
yeah
yeah tell me that story thing no we we
shot america over the span of a month
during a heat wave and
it was so hot that over the span of me
like doing pirouettes and pirouettes and
all of the glorious things that i get to
do i burned holes in my shoes how
amazing is that
i literally
like what
okay so you had
profound discussions with rina moreno
about
her experience making the film as anita
and there was something you've put out
on social media a secret that she told
you and only you
that she wish she had done differently
yes
she did
um
oh we're doing this aren't we
no she did um you know and it it i i
have
said that i'm not going
to give that away just yet because i
think it's really fun to play a game
with everybody and i want you to slip
into my dms and guess
but
i give you a clue i would love a clip
i'll give you a clue thank you it
the the note or suggestion she gave me
takes place in a scene
that we both of our anita's played
if someone puts out on social media
the correct answer will you
acknowledge that it's the right answer
yes great okay
yeah i will i should come up with a
prize i guess i don't know what it would
be
oh gosh
can i guess if it has to do with that
pivotal scene in the film
or is it another scene
okay
got it
oh that scene oh my gosh i you know i um
i people like to ask me if i had a lot
of agita about that scene and also in
this version of the film it's the it's
the one scene that i actually play with
rita moreno that's right yes and quite
frankly it's disturbing yes to hear
people say those things number one to a
woman
just period to a woman you should
these things are not acceptable even
when they're born of great grief because
that's the reality these boys make a
choice
born from intense intense grief but it
does not excuse the behavior and that's
the conversation we have to have that is
so well put thank you for putting it
that way thank you
well those boys are coming on the show
yeah and i went out to stage door manor
with ansel elgort
and rachel
came on the show and i gave her a final
five can i do that with you yes of
course okay great here we go
all right
number one the last lie you told
right now because i i don't remember
what the lie was i'm not sure is that a
lie that might be a lie
one behind the scenes detail that no one
would know um
i have vintage undergarments on in every
scene and they're highly uncomfortable
you're welcome
okay what's your latest food craving
mac and cheese that's my favorite food
on the planet
yesterday oh my gosh okay a song that we
all need to put into heavy rotation
right now oh
you know what
you should all start listening to wear
your crown which was the end credits of
the prom run on uh ryan represent
netflix but it's a really great song and
it's about um
i don't know empowerment loving yourself
you better wear your crown okay your
favorite sunday movie
you know what
ever after no yes
yes
favorite sunday movie
[Applause]
like oh my god it's a go-to it's a
staple in my home i love that movie you
are so brilliant in that movie i
literally i love you i love you
[Applause]
well that feels very fitting because
that's a film that turns a stereotype of
a fairy tale and gender on its head the
girl rescues herself and your strength
in what you portray with anita
i mean rita moreno won the academy award
you deserve it too curious
oh my god i'm gonna cry
thank you
oh my god i'm really crying you guys
this is terrible i do because you put
all of that work into it years of effort
and you are a revelation in this movie
as anita
thank you
thank you
thank you so much i really appreciate it
thank you ari anna dubose thank you so
much for your support
tomorrow
it's gonna change the world it was meant
to do that and it will
[Music]